en proposant une droite décomplexée
j'ai senti qu'il fallait des hommes
politiques qui disent tout haut ce que
les gens pensent tous bonjour chers amis
bonjour connaît un
talent a pas marre d'emmerder les
français alors chers collègues c'est
impossible détruire une forêt millénaire
pour construire un village loisirs danse
et norouet on s'amusait plus avec
l'ancien jeu font que tu m'as titre ça
rigolo mireille
dans ce projet les 55 boutiques et les
eaux décembre piscine à vagues seront
recyclés pour l'arrosage des deux golfs
est ce qu'on veut faire plus écolo que
ça
demain vous votez pour moi longtemps
même si j'étais pour ma part convaincre
les autres mais vous plaisantez la
gauche avoue mangent dans la main
[Musique]
dix y coller tous les deux ans en colère
l'un derrière l'autre
vous-même viol à knonau zh elle nous a
cloné gauche droite gauche droite haut
et
la peur elle a changé quand on s'engage
il faut que vous compreniez que vous
voulez passer de bipèdes ou quadrupèdes
vous baissez votre froc devant n'importe
quel oubli est un bel exemple changer -
est-ce qu'on a vidéosurveillées les
vaches en somme
mais gilet jaune les antilles vague les
anti viande c'est vraiment devenu
intenable
[Musique]
photo sipa tout va comme ça sera fait
si on parlait plus des migrateurs que
des migrants des campagnes électorales
moins pourri
je vais changer tu commences à me plaire
de plus en plus toi
[Musique]
tens légèrement ouvert comme ça appuie
sur la droite légèrement aussi et